They want what you got
[Mom coughing]
Mom!
There has been a second coming of Jesus
Shuttlesworth
Twenty years to the day
Lincoln High School has once again
produced the most sought-after
high school basketball prospect
Coney Island
Known for its high crime rates
and rampant drug use
Faith Mothershed has overcome the odds
This is your moment
It's your time
Do you think she's overrated?
Overrated? No way!
Think Maya Moore
Think Brittney Griner
Now stop thinking about them
Because Faith is on another level
She was clapping boards at age 12!
Faith is dope
Oh man
Tell me you seen Faith Mothershed ball
[Singing] Faith Mothershed
We have Faith Mothershed in studio today
I know you grew up in the same neighborhood
as Jesus Shuttlesworth
Everyone used to watch him play at the parks
and his jump shot, his crossover
Definitely motivated me to play basketball
Faith is the future of basketball
There's no one like her
She is not only important to basketball
but she is important to the culture
I hope she keeps her head on straight
She stays focused
We've had the best on the cover
We NEED Faith
And all eyes are on her as she decides
What to do with her future
He had a big decision to make
And you have one as well
I wanna make the best decision for us
You got game now she got game
I heard she might skip school
And just go to Russia to play
You gotta go to Russia and get this shmoney!
I don't know
I mean, look at me I'm Gucci down
Big State is one of the most dominant women's programs out there
I know we're far from New York
If you come here, your life is set up for success
I know Boro College probably isn't high on your list
But we heard about your mom
You could stay close to her
I see championships in your future
Professional career
In less than a week
Faith will answer some school's prayers
You gotta do what's best for you
[Many voices] She Got Game